[Music]  I know that you've occasionally shot  things that are not we're not allowed to  be aired you could shot something you  wanted it yeah we shot this bit where I  dress up like Ronald McDonald and I went  into a McDonald's  and legal  I can't imagine why they wouldn't let  you do that  the legal department was actually cool  with it but ad sales is like dude we put  toys or Cartoon Network we put toys and  Happy Meals this isn't happening but  actually I brought that clip too well  maybe you can't show it we're going to  show it okay yeah and then this has  never been you know it's never been seen  on TV so that's all the setup we need  this is you surprising uh random  McDonald's dressed as Ronald McDonald St  Louis the boss is here everybody  you guys just leave it on the job back  to work  I'm the boss who's the manager  the highest  you're fired  through failure  to McDonald's  [Applause]  oh man that was hilarious